the OG crypto derivatives platform and
the best place to buy your Bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to the Leia
hail pen show today we are talking about
the war and masculinity and I'm speaking
to one of the very first people to ever
be canceled now before I bring my guests
on I do want to let you know that as
usual this is sponsored by bitmex so
bitmex is the OG crypto derivatives
exchange and now has a spot exchange for
you to buy and sell your crypto
especially in a bull market you need a
name that you can trust bitmex sets the
standard in reliability performance and
transparency and has actually proven
itself through multiple Market cycles
and has stood the test of time right now
bitmex is actually celebrating the start
of bitmex spot with one million dollars
in prizes to give away so to enter all
you need to do is trade the equivalent
of 250 dollars so you could grab some
Bitcoin during the crash you can enter
up to 25 times and one lucky winner will
even receive 500 000 in Bitcoin so just
sign up I've left all the information
for you in the description below and
also a massive shout out to bitmex
because without them we wouldn't
actually be able to have such important
conversations we're seeing a lot of
censorship and deep platforming and so
without bitmax we wouldn't be able to
make this happen now before I bring on
my guest please don't forget to hit the
Subscribe button and the like button so
I can continue to bring you such
important content
now joining me on the show today is the
co-founder of Vice the founder of proud
boys and one of the very first people to
be canceled anti-platformed is also the
founder of sensor TV it is Gavin McInnis
it's bring Gavin on the show Gavin
welcome how are you I'm good how are you
doing
I'm good thank you I'm good
um I'm very excited to speak with you I
feel like um as with many things right
now
um things are sort of going around full
circle a lot of things which were being
spoken about in 2017 and even earlier
um and those people got canceled are
sort of coming back again
um so it's great to have you on I'm
happy to be here
so like I said you are one of the very
first people to be de-platformed I just
want to go back and sort of understand
what happened what did you do that was
just so controversial
[Music]
well I've been sort of micro canceled a
million times for saying things like
there's no such thing as trans they're
just mentally ill gays women would be
much happier at home that kind of stuff
that wasn't really an issue though I was
still relatively mainstream and could
get normal guests on my show until the
proud boys and once the proud boys
started fighting antifa and being proud
of their masculinity I became persona
non grata because Men's Clubs are
verboten they were ubiquitous from the
Industrial Revolution up until Gloria
steinen in the 80s and then it just was
decided no men can't congregate and have
clubs that's evil so they make up lies
they say it's a white supremacist Club
they say it's a domestic terrorist Club
it's really just it's really just Animal
House meets the Knights of Columbus and
that is not allowed in this day and age
especially when they start fighting
antifa because that's the paramilitary
wing of the DNC and they need their
street soldiers so we pose this ominous
threat and I had to go proud boys had to
go anyone who's remotely associated with
the group had to go and now you know
there's like five of them in prison for
various offenses from Jan 6 to fighting
antifa
so proud boys like you said has now now
has these racist connotations how how
did that happen
um and what was the what was the goal
then of proud boys in the first place
you say a men's club but we're like What
does that mean
men's club is just you know you Remember
The Flintstones they were they were in
the water buffaloes and they had their
big horns there and their ritual men
love a place after work where they can
go and have three dollar beers in a
clubhouse and have these ceremonies
where they only only they know the
secret handshake and there's no women to
pull out a chair as Ann Coulter said she
goes they uh they can make fart jokes
and stuff and not worry about if there
aren't pit smell or if they they burp
and they said no you can't do that so
then men started going to strip clubs
the feminists drove men to strip clubs
and as Ann put it she goes there's no
women there I mean sorry there's no
ladies there there's women but there's
no ladies and it's ironic that the the
feminist drove men to strip clubs just
so they could be alone together you know
they're always encroaching on our spaces
barbershops dive bars
the garage like just leave us alone we
don't come to your hair salon but anyway
um my I'm in the Knights of Columbus and
it's a charitable organization but it's
it's all geriatrics and I love those
guys but I thought I want to do a young
version of this so we did we had we made
up the rituals we made up the rules we
made up the ceremony the church that we
have and we just started drinking beer
and telling dirty jokes and we we were
sort of all over the map politically but
after Trump we started focusing more on
Trump and liberals got uncomfortable
with the edgy jokes and uh and then I
was doing a talk at NYU and I got jumped
by antifa they pepper sprayed me but I
happened to be with the guys and they
beat the crap out of them
eight eight or nine antifa went to jail
two proud boys did uh it was just an
absolute Slaughter and then we started
saying okay let's start bodyguarding
various conservative speakers especially
females Lauren Southern and Coulter
Michelle Malkin Heather McDonald anyone
who's doing a talk will make sure that
they're safe from antifa and then that
ended up extending to rallies because
two of the guys got arrested Max hair
and John Kinsman I'm gonna go visit them
in prison tomorrow actually they got
arrested for a 17 second fight with
antifa and that's when the club sort of
went okay now we gotta start going to
rallies and protesting which I don't
really think that was a good move
especially when you're going to every
single rally including January 6 which I
said was a bad idea and now they're
facing 22 years to life
for Meandering through the capital
so you don't see this with antifa they
just had two antifa lawyers who Molotov
cocktailed a police van burst into
flames they were handing out Molotov
cocktails they refused a plea deal for a
year
because the courts are infiltrated by
radical leftists Soros appointed DA's
and they could literally get away with
murder so it's a really strange time and
start answering your first part of the
question about the racist thing that's
just what the left does our side calls
everyone a pedophile their side calls
everyone a Nazi I don't think either are
true in most cases but it's just the
go-to word I mean Trump how many times
have you heard Trump compared to Hitler
it's just lazy analogy that everyone
boring does
so who do you think is behind this
de-platforming
well that's a good question I I think um
it's it's the global Elites it's Soros
it's the DNC but if they didn't have
lackeys at these companies then it
wouldn't be effective
so there's these fat
ugly losers that work in big tech
companies that play video games so much
as a woman they think they're trans
they're not they're just boring they're
not even gay And when they see proud
boys you know uh promote masculinity and
pride in Western culture they're
reminded of the guys who wedgied them in
junior high so they happily push delete
because right now we're living in this
Epoch of Revenge of the Nerds it's it's
revenge of the the oppressed uh Geeks
and they're happy to carry out the dnc's
bidding because it means punishing the
bullies who made them uncomfortable when
they were 13.
so let's talk about this um this war on
masculinity
um
you that that was basically the reason
why you started proud boys
um what do you think is the problem with
masculinity like why why don't the
elites want masculinity why are these as
you put it these these fat women sitting
at their desks at these Tech
organizations you know what's the
problem with masculinity why can't you
have a men's club
because masculinity tends to involve
meritocracy men have had power for
thousands of years and we're good at it
now
uh we're Fair we're just that's why
America is the best place to be if
you're a gay or a visible minority or a
weirdo you're safest here in the west
because men have mastered power
unfortunately the Nerds took over
somewhere around the late 80s and 90s
and now Patton Oswald is considered a
cool influencer with power you know the
Geeks are in control and they don't want
to give up that power they love it it's
like Gollum in the ring they want to
keep their precious and it sucks when
they're in power because they're bad at
it women tend to be really bad at Power
they they get vindictive they they want
to hurt people they want to destroy
their enemies they want to literally
kill their enemies and right now Trump
and everyone normal is saying okay you
had a good run but uh you suck at this
we're taking the reins back and we're
working out we're not ashamed we're not
apologizing
for creating the modern world we're
going to return to meritocracy because
you guys are ruining the country the
culture and I mean the I think the last
draw excuse me
the last drop
has been this war on kids where they're
giving prepubescent children puberty
blockers that's where we I think every
dad got up off the couch all right all
right no no no no no no stop stop stop
you're cutting off lesbians tits no no
no no we're not doing this anymore move
step aside step aside
so after a quarter Century of taking a
break from masculinity meritocracy
Western Pride uh we're taking it back
because it's just better
and you're totally right there's a
massive war on um children right now um
I think I think it's so sad um but it
didn't start off that way um you were
actually one of the first people who
started calling out this wokeness so
what was it specifically
um that you know opened your eyes to
this what were you calling out initially
well personally I had a real 90 degree
turn in my political interests after 9
11 where I was there I watched the
second plane hit I watched The Towers
fall and I started saying what's going
on now with Islam what have you guys
been doing I I gave you my tax dollars
but I wasn't really paying attention and
then I started paying attention and I
saw that people would literally rather
die than be seen as racist also coming
from from Quebec Montreal where the war
there is English versus French and it
gives you a real solid perspective when
you come to America and everyone is it's
all about race and you're like race you
mean black people those like if you're
black in Montreal you're a rich Haitian
nerd who managed to had enough money to
get out of Haiti so you wear a tie and
if you go to a haitian's party in
Montreal it's like Coke and chips they
don't even drink so I'm like why are we
talking about those black nerds all the
time and you realize how frivolous it is
and how silly it is to be totally
consumed with race every day talking
about the KKK for crying out loud
there's probably 17 members in the
entire 331 million population here in
America like Drop it God it's so boring
but
I started calling that out and it was
acceptable really you could be dangerous
and you could you could mock the left
until Trump and when Trump gained power
they said oh wait a minute these Edge
Lords these trolls these Pepe the Frog
guys uh actually can win and that's when
they went in to cancel overdrive and you
know they tried debating us at first and
that was the sort of history of America
America was always right versus left
even before America
the whole East Coast the the the Brits
said we want newspapers but have a right
one and a left one and always be arguing
with each other that's very healthy so
it's and then we we argued so much we
got smarter and said let's kick out the
king and take over this country and make
it ours so that's that's it's intrinsic
in the American landscape is to have
this back and forth and we had Gore
Vidal and William F Buckley and it was
always common but that all ended with
Trump because the left
the Marxist destroyed education so now
they're [ __ ] they don't know
anything ask them ask a liberal in
America how many illegals there are in
this country ask him how many came
through the Border since Biden ask him
how many is too many
they can't even answer that ask them
what eight times seven is actually while
you're at it and so they stopped
debating us because they always lose I
mean go online you see Stephen Crowder
going to various colleges Charlie Kirk
eviscerating college students Ben
Shapiro eating kids alive it's pathetic
how bad they are and so they said okay
well I can't debate him let's just cut
him off and the beauty of that is you
can make up insane allegations and you
can't defend yourself and you you can
dehumanize them deperson them and once
they're deep person you can kill them
that's ultimately their goal they want
us dead
can you be more specific about the
agenda like what do you mean they want
us there does that mean like
depopulation does that mean you know
like they only want you know people on
the right of Center to be dead like what
does that mean what is the actual agenda
going on here effective Charming
pro-trump people to die
they want Ann Coulter to die they want
Michelle Malkin to die they want Steve
Bannon to die
they want Donald Trump Jr to go to jail
for life for no apparent crime
why
because he's a threat to their power and
the Nerds the losers have been in charge
now since the 90s it's been cool to be a
geek it's been cool to be a radical
Lefty for a long ass time now and these
people I remember them in the early 90s
from when I was in college and they were
nuts you know you'd meet a lesbian
separatist who's so feminist she doesn't
want men in the world so you'd meet her
you'd go to shake her hand she goes I
don't touch men they're almost like
Catholic Jews with their Devotion to
feminism and and
lesbianity and you just go okay well
you're a nut that's fine I don't care
you're obviously a small minority now
that woman is a judge she's a journalist
at the New York Times she's a prosecutor
like we have the prosecutors here in New
York who say all cops are bastards they
hate cops and they're open about it on
Twitter like the radical nuts that I
went to college with in the 90s are now
the establishment and they're drunk with
power they suck at it and they know they
can't debate us or deal with his
marriage on a with a meritocracy they
can't even deal with us in court so they
just throw us in jail and throw away the
key and they also threaten our children
like they come after my wife and kids so
I never put my kids up on social media
or anything like that or show my wife
the space anywhere and now I'm less of a
person now I'm less of a family man now
I'm easier humanized because I can't
show Chris Hayes he can take a picture
with his kids on a bike ride and
everyone's like oh he's a family man
Gavin is this evil Hitler Pariah with no
family context because that's been
erased
so it's an effective strategy but but
hurting kids I think was a really dumb
move this drag queen Story Hour having
eight-year-olds put money in a [ __ ]
homosexuals panties was a stupid move
they just they lost they lost half their
base with that move it was really was it
stupid or was it calculated like are
they trying to purposely destabilize the
Next Generation
don't put don't give too much
credibility to these people don't don't
assume that there's a grand plan there
is with some of the globalists like
Soros and everything but the average
dumb teacher with a trans flag in her
room she's just a vindictive [ __ ] and
the only reason she's doing it is
because she thinks it makes rednecks mad
all of their their entire political
belief system is predicated on spite
don't go deeper than that it's just I
want to make Gavin grit his teeth I want
to make the average Mega dad clench his
fists they don't go past that the fact
that they're torturing a child and
having her breasts removed is is
ancillary that's that's irrelevant
that's collateral damage as long as I'm
hurting that racist redneck Pig
and it's a strange Revenge because they
don't even have the the the guy right
the guy that they hate isn't a racist
racism is not a thing
despite it being the backbone of the
left's Crusade against us we aren't
racist you stupid idiots
but you see those types of people like
you said you know they're just they're
coming from it they're coming at it from
either like a do go to angle or they're
trying to like you said you know upset
the Rednecks or whatever it is but that
kind of division and divisiveness
definitely comes from a higher place
right like you mentioned George Soros
the elites so I want I want to get in
into that and understand like what your
take is on those Elites how deep does it
go a lot of people point to like the
world economic forum and all of that you
know what's your take
yeah so the top brass the elites the
globalists the the Klaus Schwab the the
George sorosis of the world they want to
destroy Society flatten it just like the
floods just like Moses and then rebuild
it back in their image we're there in
control where they can have monopolies
where they decide Gillette makes all the
razors and there's a czar of bathroom
care you know that's fascism by the way
that's dictionary definition of fascism
you have these various czars appointed
to various Global uh industries that
there's the the head of energy for Earth
right so that's their plan and the best
way to do that is division and to to
call everyone racist and and convince
the left that they're fighting this
moral Crusade
but it's incredibly effective because
they've lobotomized the left and they
all we're talking about millions of
people who are are uh what's the word
there uh useful idiots they're two
idiots yeah yeah they're tools to
facilitate this I mean they're they're
rejecting their family members at
Thanksgiving because their their family
members don't believe in the vaccine uh
they're they're canceling Christmas
because one of the the cousins is a
trump supporter I know a guy
a black dude uh who was on my show I'm
blanking on his name but he uh
what's that guy's name again the guy
who's the anti-feminist dude
no black guy [ __ ]
there's so many
anyway he he's been on my show a few
times he's was kicked out of
Thanksgiving because he's a trump guy
but the there's a cousin there who has a
record of of pedophilia who had molested
a nine-year-old oh wow Sotomayor
uh who molested a nine-year-old that guy
is at the dinner that's acceptable
I mean Jeffrey Dahmer they were doing a
documentary on Jeffrey Dahmer and he
found out about it he contacted the
documentarians it's an old one
and he said hey I just want to make it
clear uh I ate black people because I
lived in a black neighborhood I'm not
racist
so for this guy being a cannibal is
pretty bad but it's not as bad as being
a racist that was his big fear so that
it's amazing how these elitists are able
to manipulate almost 50 percent of the
population with ridiculous lies and it's
amazing it's satanic when your victims
being children it's demonic as Dan
Coulter would say oh it's absolutely
demonic even the music nowadays is
demonic I can't listen to it
um but you know I think I think like
with regards like the war of masculinity
I think that is
um ramping up a lot it's actually one of
the reasons why I left London because I
found the men like ridiculously feminine
um and every time I try and explain to
people
um you know there's a war of masculinity
I I find it sometimes really hard to
sort of like you know give great
examples so I'd love to hear you know
some examples that you could give of you
know how they're how's this war on
masculinity like like how do we see it
shoes
they're wearing they're wearing slides
they're wearing shower shoes and they're
not even they're not they don't even fit
well they're sort of puffy like a
sleepover girl would wear their their
first slumber parties those big foamy
Yeezy slides uh flip-flops I mean
flip-flops are basically hiking boots at
this point these kids are walking around
in in pajama bottoms Crocs women with
these [ __ ] eyelashes which I'll
never get used to I hate those things
and and black girls now in the hood
we're in the South Bronx here they just
wear shower caps all day the everyone is
is Blended into this this world of
leisure where like my son wanted to get
uh Birkenstocks and I said there's no
stocks Crocs or dreadlocks in this house
and he goes why not I go what if someone
slaps your girl
how are you going to fight in
Birkenstocks you need to have shoes on
be a man
and when you look at their body shapes
the amount of men I keep saying these
lesbians were cutting their tits off
ladies about half the guys I know have
tits go to like a water park the
majority of men have breasts I mean the
level of testosterone in the average
male is half of what it was in the 50s
and here's something no one ever talks
about by the way one of the problems
with uh
this is birth control pills you know
Alex Jones is mocked for saying they're
making the frogs gay but if you look at
the water supply there is excess
estrogen and amphibians can choose their
sex to it in a sense when they're when
they're uh tadpole age and they tend to
adhere to more female than male because
there's more estrogen in the water it's
affecting the frogs that's what he meant
whenever Alex says something crazy go
look it up and you realize oh it's
actually true he's just saying it in the
cookie way
so the way birth control works is it
tells your body that you're in the uh I
think first trimester of pregnancy
so you don't produce any more eggs you
don't have a little home for the baby
because the baby's already there but
it's not there it's a trick
so when women are in this state they
don't want to get ravaged they don't
want to be made love to they don't want
to be taken away by a macho man on a
horse they want a brotherly like figure
someone who's going to protect them but
not sexually molest them so they're
attracted to kind weak beta male friends
who are not sexual at all and Men
they're anyone's dog for a bone if women
were into clowns I'd have a red nose on
right now let's just we'll do whatever
you want so if the free market of of
dating is women looking for a brother
then men are like okay I'm a sexless
friend who will protect you so we have
this there could be a chemical impetus
for these castrated men where they're
just doing what the the [ __ ] Market
says and the [ __ ] Market saying be a
wimp and they're doing an excellent job
of it
I actually think you're totally correct
um I saw somebody had tweeted something
the other day saying that birth control
is making women pick the wrong men
um and it's completely true and I think
as well that you're right women actually
hold the key to everything if um if
women liked clowns yeah you'd be dressed
in a clown suit
um it's completely correct because these
women marry their brother right they go
off birth control and they're like who
is this wimp in a pink shirt in my
living room it's so sad what happened I
want a real man now and he's like sorry
I'm a friend and then they get they
break up and she wants a real man then
she goes back on birth control because
she's single and she attracts another
brotherly figure and then she gets
married to him goes awkward control
dumps him because he's a wimp and so on
and so on it's ruining women's lives
women are not being able to settle down
until they're 40 and then they go okay I
want a kid now and it's like sorry your
ovaries dried up so then they get on
fertility medicine and then they end up
having like quintuplets where seven of
them die I and they have one that's
octuplets I guess and that kid is has
Asperger's or he's on the spectrum
because you had him so late he's damaged
what a mess yeah I think it's so sad I'm
I'm with you and you said something
which was really interesting actually
you said you know you don't want your
sons to wear Birkenstock or Crocs
because you know how you're going to
protect your woman and that's actually
really fascinating because the um idea
around toxic masculinity is that these
men are evil they're dangerous they must
be banished from society but every man
that I speak to
um who you know I can have these kind of
conversations with is always talking
about protecting women
um that's sort of like the priority here
you know protecting women you told me
that you're there protecting Lauren
Southern and many other conservative
women so
um why don't we you know look to that
why don't we appreciate that look there
are actually men here that want to
protect you women didn't invent feminism
men did you go back to the 16th century
and when a man would beat a woman they
used to throw him in jail and then they
went wait a minute if he's in jail he
can't make any money for this family his
family starve so now we're punishing
women and children for being beaten by a
man so then they said I know let's just
put him in the stocks and we'll beat the
[ __ ] out of him and throw rotten food at
him for a day and then we'll let him out
and he can get back to work and support
his family that was pre-feminism we've
always been concerned with women and
children and and their their safety but
that's why I said the patriarchy is the
safest place for all these people if
these lunatic homosexuals radical
leftists these marxists if they get in
control then the artist in the creative
class will be the first to go believe me
you want if you're a raging queer a
musician you want Archie Bunker in
charge you know Archie the it's the
homophobes like me who when the
government says all gays must die we go
oh for crying out loud and we go
downstairs and we get our guns and we
say gays get in the basement I got this
and we go defend them because it's wrong
you can't just kill people
your safest with us folks we've been
doing the power thing for thousands of
years and we've we've got it down you're
not good at it yeah I totally agree with
you um where do you think the
indoctrination is coming because when I
was like as a teenager you know I'd say
I was pretty woke as a teenager but the
older I get the more I've like done a
completely uh 360 or a 180 um you know
so it you know is it coming from like
the media the schools the music the
movies Hollywood well if you want to do
a deep dive I mean it's the Baby Boomers
the Baby Boomers were spoiled and they
hated themselves because they had no
grit they look at their parents the
silent generation and they go my dad had
no shoes when he was a kid I've been
pampered my whole life so they were
desperate for some sort of substance and
when Martin Luther King was killed in 69
they started this whole you know civil
rights Crusade and they're like yes I
finally got a thing I'm a revolutionary
man power to the people off the pig and
you had the weather underground and you
know aim and the Chicano Liberation
movement and all these revolutionaries
the flq up in Quebec and they were
murdering people they were shooting
breaks security guards in the head they
were killing cops they were getting
money for their dumb mostly black
revolutions they'd get money to give to
the Black Panthers or these black
revolutionaries and around that time you
had Bill Ayers of the Weather
Underground who's a genius and a demon
and he realized the best way to foment a
true solid Revolution is to start with
the children so he gets his PhD in early
childhood education you'll notice a lot
of them are really into early childhood
education and they eventually indoctrine
indoctrinate kids like when my son I
live in a liberal Enclave in Westchester
when my son was at pre-k
Trump was just running
and I'm walking him home he goes I hate
Trump he's four
and I go why do you hate Trump and he
goes because he doesn't listen
and I go good we don't want him to
listen we want an independent president
yeah so what the Billiards whether
underground that these freak hippies of
the 70s have done is they started
brainwashing our children uh when they
became teachers and professors and
kindergarten teachers up to professors
they managed to destroy college
education and turn that into an
indoctrination camp but what's very
dangerous is K-12 they've infiltrated
K-12 and if you talk to a six-year-old
about black lives matter he'll sound
like he works at black lives matter you
know mainstream America realizes from
Kanye to to Pat Buchanan that BLM is a
scam it's it's a pretty well-known fact
now not with little kids with little
kids power to the people they sound like
their ancestors the The Weather
Underground from the early 70s from that
movement they've they've taken over and
you know you gotta you don't homeschool
you got to spend some time
after school with your kids every day
unraveling the BS
like the the Tulsa Massacre they're told
blacks built up a wall Street and then
the government went no way not on my
watch we don't want no Negroes making
their own economy so we bombed it no
there was a race riot started by black
people because some black kid groped a
lady and she pressed charges the black
guy showed up at the police station to
free him white guy showed up too guns
went off a fight broke out the riot blew
up they started burning down buildings
because blacks were shooting from the
buildings it was 100 about race that
Riot and eventually the the planes which
was Farmers trying to spot snipers this
went on for days by the way eventually
the Whiteside one and that was in that
it was not some grand scheme to wipe out
Black Wall Street and it wasn't Black
Wall Street it was just the local
business board like here in the South
Bronx if you own a bodega you're you're
part of the South Bronx business
Coalition and they got these guys go to
the they Lobby the city for different
you know to fix a pot whole that kind of
thing that's what it was they didn't
have their own currency it wasn't black
crypto but kids are taught that in
schools
unravel it when they come back I just
tell my boy the other day he goes yeah
we're learning about racism in class
today and police violence and I'm like
okay son
blacks I mean sorry police have about 60
million interactions with citizens a
year if you look up all the unarmed
blacks who were killed you'll notice it
they there's like people there's guys
chasing cops with cars and they just
dropped a knife you'll usually find like
six cases where you go oh that seems
pretty bad actually so that's six out of
60 million that's one in 10 million
that's pretty good your odds of being
hit by a car are much higher than one in
10 million so
I have to explain Brianna Taylor was a
drug dealer who was in a shootout I had
to explain that that uh George Floyd was
complaining he couldn't breathe from
fentanyl way before Derek Chauvin ever
showed up I have to explain that Mike
Brown didn't have his hands up he was
terrorizing the neighborhood refused to
comply and then reached for an officer's
gun I have to explain to Sandra Bland
was suicidal and she finally managed to
pull it off in jail where she ended up
because she was mounting off to a police
officer and refused to comply uh what
the other guy Freddie not Freddie Roach
the heroin dealer guy who died in police
custody he was banging his own head
against the police fan so he could sue
them for abuse and he overdid it like
all of these cases that we all take for
granted I have a story behind them and
now because of all this propaganda we
have castrated police I mean
anti-masculinity has dripped into the
military
force the FDNY the fire department it's
everywhere it's like a plague it's a
virus that's infected our community and
now we have police lives in danger
because they're so worried about being
the next Derek Chauvin Chauvin I guess
I'm supposed to pronounce it
why are your kids still in those schools
then if you have to keep repeating
they're not I don't talk I can't talk
about specifics my kids but uh yeah they
they we've taken action on that issue
solved you should have seen this reading
list my son got a couple years ago when
he was in junior high it was 19 books
and not one of them was a white male and
they were all genderqueer and a lot tons
and tons of books about the KKK and
slavery with like a little black girl
like this and a burning cross behind her
I did a video on you can you can find it
and I talked to the superintendent
schools and I said look I'm not looking
for you know white male Paradise here I
don't want every book to be about white
males but out of 19 books there should
be one white male protagonist equality
right
what about Atticus Finch yeah there it
is or uh what about the guy who signed
Jackie Robinson and I'm like dude a book
about Jackie Robinson uh is about Jackie
Robinson not the dude who signed him and
Atticus Finch To Kill a Mockingbird is
about a little white girl learning that
America is racist and often gets the
wrong guy
so no those don't count and you know
what's crazy about all this it's not
like the kids read these books and go oh
I guess there are tons of genders and oh
I guess we are horrible slave owners and
oh I guess everyone is bigoted America's
steeped in systemic racism you know what
they do the kids I meet I know them I
see them they sleep over my house they
think books are gay
so instead of it's like a participation
trophy you don't go yeah I win too you
just go oh I don't want those everyone
has one so they've they ruined trophies
and they ruin books none of my kids
friends read books and I'm like there's
cool edgy books there out there there's
Jack Kerouac there's Hunter S Thompson
there's Confederacy of Dunces there's
Tibor Fisher read this book by Michelle
Malkin who built that read this book by
Glenn Beck Miracles and massacres I
could show you fun books they could be
edgy there's swear words in them
that's not how they see books anymore
when they think of a book they think of
some graphic novel about uh some gay
dude blowing his friend in junior high
and they're like yeah no thanks thanks
by the way uh lefties for ruining an
entire division of our culture
they ruined books um what would you
teach your sons
um that uh masculinity is like what what
is manhood what does it mean to be a man
that's a good question and it's it's
hard to articulate but Grit
a Mobility bravery loyalty
physical fitness
and being a handshake guy being a man of
your word
being honest and telling the truth and
never stabbing anyone in the back not
taking advantage of situations if you
have to trample someone else and being
proud you know winning
I remember when my my youngest boy was
was seven he won he won a tournament a
baseball tournament the entire
tournament they were the champions of
the league and so all the dads are
high-fiving and there was a French dude
there who just moved from France
and his son was terrible at baseball not
just because they were French just
wasn't in there's no testosterone in
there and you need some to play baseball
and I go I go to high five I'm Jacques
we won and he goes uh I wouldn't want to
be that guy and he points to the catcher
of the other team who was crying by the
way there's no crying in baseball
and he that was his Focus was that the
other team was crying because they lost
and I'm like I go dude you don't get
America you don't get it we won it's
time to celebrate and that's part of
being a man is being Unapologetic
and the finally
you can't cry
now if you're watching a war movie you
can have one of these tiers
but yeah there we go
ever even if your parents die right in
front of you if your parents die and
you're at the funeral the most a man can
cry is to go
oh god oh
oh God
that's a mat and that's like people are
dead
yeah
it's interesting because um they all
sound like very attractive qualities
um you know I'm very
um open and very honest and I think most
women will say oh no men should be able
to cry
um but I'm just gonna be honest like no
like women women don't like that women
are lying when they say they are like
fancy men fight if a man is fighting
especially if he has a cigarette in his
mouth the whole fight women are like
gushing like they want to come over and
make out I when I was dating my wife I
got in a fight and I noticed she was
making out with me as I was pounding the
guy in the face it's it's a very Prime
especially American Indian woman they
really seem to love violence but it's a
very primal thing and we love women too
like Tucker Carlson was saying the other
day he goes I've always I'm a big fan of
women it's when it's what we've done to
them I call them [ __ ] chests you know
because you know Tony Starks the Iron
Man he's got that blue orb that keeps
him alive so Tony Starks is cool he can
fly around and save the day and he has
these cool Powers thanks to that thing
if you were to take that out and replace
it with feces he'd be a garbage person
he wouldn't be magic he wouldn't and
this is what we've done with women we've
taken away their femininity their innate
fragility their beauty their their
Oneness with nature and their magical
power where they can make babies that's
the blue orb and we've taken it out and
put [ __ ] there they're [ __ ] chests and
they walk around going I'm tough yeah I
want to fight like you you watch street
fights now on the Internet or even in
real life and you'll see these women
jumping in [ __ ] you [ __ ] like trying to
beat out and you're like ladies get out
of here like Heather heyer she goes to
Charlottesville to beat up Nazis in
sweatpants and flip-flops and you're
like if these guys are who you say they
are which is the people who are about to
start World War Three you should at
least have some like knee pads and
helmets on and be practiced in the
martial arts but so these women are
trying to be men they're trying to take
over male characteristics and they suck
they suck at being men and men so suck
at being women look at these [ __ ]
they look like Mrs Doubtfire it's
hilarious I can't stop laughing and
they're like someone left me today why
can't I pass because women make crappy
men and men make crappy women stop
trying to change it you look like fools
what do you think so what do you think
came first
um I and I speak to a lot of men and
they do actually blame men because I
think that like women have definitely
become more masculine and I feel like
they've done that because men haven't
been able to be men like I feel like
femininity can flourish in a safe
masculine space
um and so if men aren't being masculine
then women naturally will step up and
will have to sort of fill that void what
do you think which came first yeah who
started it that's a good question I
think you know the 80s we had our rolls
down and when people say make America
great again they mean the 80s yeah I
mean
pit vipers and mullets and jet skis Alex
P Keaton on Family Ties that's what
they're going for then in the 90s we had
this sort of anti-fashion thing which I
just got back from Paris and it's big
over there now being ugly and being lazy
and looking like crap uh women started
wearing Doc Martin shoes and baggy pants
and stupid shirts with like boy hairdos
and boys just had that sort of I'm a
creep I'm a weirdo shoe gazing
sweatshirt stuff where they became
emasculated and I think they were pretty
simultaneous and they're both really bad
for each other but then around the 2000s
it went into overdrive so we went from
men being these shoegazing wimps like
Radiohead dude and girls just being dumb
ravers like Chloe 70 and kids to women
wanting to be like Superman and men
wanting to be raging Queens like Jeffree
Star doing makeup tutorials so we really
went into overdrive recently and it's
it's clown world it is a clown world
so we spoke about the war masculinity
and how that's engineered because you
know they don't like meritocracy and
obviously you know if you sort of if you
break down the men then you can break
down all of society because men are like
the The Gatekeepers they're the the the
the gods right but would you say there's
a war on um women then like an
orchestrated war on women oh absolutely
there's a war on natural women women who
are not [ __ ] chests I mean look at look
at a housewife when she's meeting her
friends what do you do for a living oh
I'm a housewife that scene is like uh
you lose
we've liberated you from the kitchen and
you wandered back in there we took off
your hijab and you went and put it back
on it meanwhile I create life and then I
shape those lives in a beautiful home
like you're a God that's why the proud
boys one of their tenants is venerate
the housewife I think there should be on
Fox News when they have a panel one of
them should have a rolling pin and an
apron on and she should be representing
the housewives I mean they determine
elections they're they're the reason
we've had Justin Trudeau for three terms
so I don't know why they're ignored as a
political force but they are a major
part of western culture and it's it's
frowned upon another thing by the way
behind all this there's a lot of daddy
issues on the left and that's why they
hate Trump for whatever reason he
represents the patriarch the father
and that's why they're doing all this
gay [ __ ] drag queen stuff because it's
an Fu to Dad and I think that might be
somewhat Justified because the Baby
Boomers invented divorce around 1980 you
didn't get divorced in the 70s it wasn't
done and then it just became the norm
from like the the early 80s and now
we're at a 50 percent divorce rate and
it's not like these dummies trade in
their old wife for a young girl that's
the stereotype in movies but we've all
seen what happens they end up marrying
someone pretty similar to their wife and
throwing away fatherhood and the the
children resent that and I think it's
Justified I think the daddy issues are
are pathetic and embarrassing and a big
part of leftist politics but I also
think they're right you're right to have
Daddy Issues if your dad started a new
family and now he's he's 50 years old
with a baby and he never played catch
with you he's not even paying child
support he's basically a sperm donor I
understand you being pissed off you
should be pissed off and men have some
culpability there the Boomers created
divorce they've ruined education they
made homes unaffordable they did a lot
of bad things but the worst thing they
did was turn their back on their family
that's unforgivable and now with my
generation I look up all the guys I went
to high school with it seems like none
of them are married with kids
and they're scared they they have PTSD
they they're once burnt twice shy and
they don't want to go near marriage
because they saw it destroy their mom's
life
it's really sad yeah I think it's so sad
um and I I see I've watched a lot of
your stuff um and um you trigger a lot
of feminists you say that women prefer
to
um uh not be working
um which I find so interesting so can
you tell me more about that
women don't belong in the workforce
generally there's a few exceptions
there's some you know talented
oncologists somewhere that's saving
children's lives and there's there's the
Maggie thatchers of the world but
being being at work is a male thing it's
aggressive you're fighting every day
like I box and when I'm at the gym
sparring with someone is not very
different from work when when you're
working you're bidding on a contract
you're competing with other bidders
you're trying to tell the person that
you're the best person for the job and
you know you're fighting for that it's
it's meetings are are a fight but you
also have to temper the fighting with
being loyal and honest and not being
petty and vindictive which is what you
do in sparring right you can't kick
someone in the balls in the ring it's
it's for both
so that's all very male things and
you'll notice when women try to do that
they go we're not making any money uh we
can't like break the glass ceiling yeah
because you don't stay overnight you
don't you don't stay up all you don't
think about your job Saturday at noon
and text your co-worker going what if we
hired a chef to make the lunch at the
office we everyone could donate and we'd
save like 200 bucks a week if we were to
do that blah blah let's stop having the
cleaners come in they're not really
cleaning much we can do it every month
these little tiny things that end up you
know culminating in major changes in a
company you know here's an example women
want to be directors they don't want to
work in sanitation by the way but they
want equal representation as directed
directing is a really hard job you have
to make sure you have both angles both
people talking
um you have to make sure you have the
the b-roll you have to make sure you
have extra stuff to cut to so you're
keeping this inventory in your head
while you're watching the scene I think
a lot of women just think it's like
you're at a movie but you're making it
no you're you're grocery shopping for
food that you're going to make later you
need all of the ingredients on top of
all of that the creativity sticking to
the script getting on the shots you have
to also have the courage and the
tenacity to go you suck you're fired we
gotta started like with Back to the
Future they had Eric Stoltz the dude
from mask they shot for like a month and
eventually the director goes this guy's
not good I want Michael J fox so they
fired him and they got Michael J fox and
it became one of the most successful
movies of all time because he made big
bold moves you have to tell everyone to
shut up everyone quiet on the set shut
up those just aren't female
characteristics so what do they do they
either become bad directors and they
ruin companies or they do the jobs they
do at home like I had lunch with Milo
recently and we said he's like tell me
think of a job where women are actually
talented at it and they they Thrive tell
me about a job where a woman has a
natural disposition to and she thrives
and we sat there for like an hour and a
half eventually we came up with real
estate agent
I think that's it but what does a real
estate agent do they do she does what a
housewife does hi welcome to my house we
just redid the kitchen oh here's the
living room we just got that couch do
you like it I don't know if I like it
it's not that comfortable but it looks
good and the tour of the house they sit
there they manage their boss's meetings
oh you have a meeting at four they
organize just like this she would
organize a family they do the social
media for a restaurant oh I run this
restaurant's Facebook we do a lot of
social media yeah that's what moms do
they post pictures of their kids camping
and when they go out on a trip it's on
Facebook and they just end up being
someone else's Mommy and someone else's
wife and sharing that love with someone
else that's how Affairs happen too you
end up falling in love with the guy and
blowing him so that women in the
workforce has been a total Abomination
and even I'm sorry but even sexual
harassment like I've had when I worked
in I had an ad Agency for a while and
these it's a lot of gays in advertising
and they'd be like you know what if you
had [ __ ] me or let me blow you you
could have had that contract I was like
well I guess we won't be getting that
contract then I can have a view of that
guy afterwards
now a woman that's major me too that's
that's Harvey Weinstein's in jail like
yeah that's no good apocalyptic if if
Ryan right now grabbed my penis or a gay
dude grab my dick I might punch him or
I'd be like dude what the are you out of
your mind what are you doing
but like a lawsuit and all of this stuff
it's just
they're just not cut out for
fighting and that's what that's what the
workforce is it's fighting
it's so funny because um I actually like
totally agree with you um and I'm
running this podcast
um right now we're gossiping like yes I
know I agree uh out on the on the back
porch right now gossiping over the fence
I totally agree with you I think um I
think you know in this world you know
everybody needs to
um you know survive and and make money
in any way that they can
um and because I am self-aware I love
doing my podcast because I'm not married
I'd love to be and I hope to be one day
very soon
mid-20s okay so we gotta get serious now
we gotta get serious oh dating musicians
no dating members no dating days
if if he doesn't seem like the right one
in a few months four months then cut
them loose agreed
uh you gotta watch out for pot here's
what I say to women your age you don't
you're not looking for a rich guy you're
looking for an ambitious guy every if
he's ambitious everything else will fall
into place if he's up at 9am on a Monday
even when he's unemployed you've got to
keep her there Netflix
you know what the problem is but you
know the problem is nowadays it's like
not a lot of men are awake to all of
this stuff you know so you have to find
somebody who's not vaccinated somebody
who's um you know awake to the reality
of you know the war and Men the war on
women
um and that that's really difficult like
I don't want to be I don't want to be
like red pilling my man like he's the
one that's supposed to teach me and red
pill me so that's that's like my only
issue is like I tend to be like smarter
than most men well you're in Miami it's
world famous as the stupidest city in
the world
no there's a lot of great people here to
be honest people always say that but
that's in great people it's not known
for its IQ
that's that's true that's true but I
think many places are these days it's
better than London so I feel I'm I'm I
feel like I'm in a good place yeah it's
more masculine than London but it's
definitely not smart
no I know you're right so out of
Interest what advice would you
do they just like dump a chick instantly
on a dating site if she's you know
pro-vax or something like that or hates
Trump I would say let politics it's not
the Beyond Endo my wife's a liberal
she's a vegan she voted for Hillary like
we get over those things I basically
read pilder now it took me 20 years but
um you know it's not like politics
should Define your entire existence and
I talk about my parents like my parents
didn't know how their neighbors voted
now in the suburbs there's entire
enclaves that are right or left you
don't see a trump sign in one lawn and a
hate has no home here signing the next
line that never happens it's either
there's American flags or there's you
know love wins signs in that entire area
and that's that's bizarre I mean your
politics I see Politics as just math
it's like there's a series of problems
with the way Society runs here's my
theory on how it could be fixed
how is that you know determining entire
futures of couples
but I think it's different when you're a
man though like when like it's okay for
you to you know spend 20 years red
pilling your wife like imagine me
spending 20 years red pity my husband
like that sounds like a miserable
existence yeah it does you know what I
mean he's apolitical and he's just
saying these things to get laid no but a
political is bad as well because you
want a man that like stands for
something and knows what the [ __ ] is
happening in this world you know it's
hard yeah well you're in a weird spot I
mean it wouldn't be hard in South
Carolina or Tennessee or anywhere sort
of north of Florida south of the
Mason-Dixon line
but Florida should be pretty good
outside of Miami a little bit no
no it is like there's a lot of great
people um and I meet a lot of great
people through work as well so I'm like
very privileged with you know the kind
of circles that I'm in so no I'm good
I'm I feel like I'll be more than yeah
if you wear heels three times a week
you'll be you'll be you'll have to lock
your door they'll be outside like
beetles
noted noted so what advice then would
you give
young uh young boys right now
um given that there's a war on
masculinity
all sphere in Love and War lie cheat
steal whatever you have to do to get in
her pants and then once you're in her
pants stay in her pants and never leave
even if you have to put Viagra in your
wallet on the off chance you get so
nervous you can't get it up you need to
perform and just don't stop talking
talking laughing [ __ ] that's the
secret to getting chicks and then I
would say you know you've been with her
for like almost a year what are you
waiting for I always say to guys that
have been with someone for like three
years and I propose I go what do you
want her but with bigger tits like what
are you waiting for put a ring on it
[ __ ] and then when you put a ring on it
start greeting like rabbits oh I can't
afford it right now kids are free you
don't have to go on vacation every year
you don't need three cars you already
have a roof over your head right
now you just got to buy more groceries
like all this waiting for money is so
stupid you think our parents had money
you think our grandparents had any money
when they had kids a kid can sleep in
the in a bassinet in the in your room
until she's like two or three or four
like just get on it and I also say to
these young people this is part of the
theme of my book death of cool I say
okay you got wasted you stole from your
parents Liquor Cabinet when you were 14
right you're 24 now
that's a Decade of Decadence of cocaine
and threesomes and and pot and puking
your guts out because you chugged uh
Fireball
are you have you not sewn your Wild Oats
yet 10 years isn't cutting it like the
stones didn't give her for 10 years
Motley Crue really just had 10 main
years Metallica so their their Peak was
of partying was 10 years now they're all
sober dude grow up
I hear you I hear you out of interest
um out of Interest what do you think
about
um I mean you're married and it sounds
like everything's going great but um you
know obviously Andrew Tate is just being
canceled and a lot of those men you know
talk about being these super masculine
high value men that will never settle
they'll always have multiple women
because they can what's your take on
that well just like try to be as ugly as
I am and you won't have you know these
men are men 10 the Modern Man tends to
be as loyal as his opportunities but and
I thought it was Johnny Knoxville and
they were banging on my door every day I
don't think I'd be able to refuse
fellatio 24 hours a day especially if I
was drunk but it doesn't really come up
and plus when you're married you don't
really give off the vibe that you're
open for business I I think I think
women are the same way when they're in a
committed relationship a man can sort of
smell that there's no chance but you
know
the Andrew Tate idea of living that
Johnny Knoxville life and just getting
laid all the time uh is gay
oh really that's a gay lifestyle banging
woman
three women a day and then three women
the next day and not knowing their names
that's a homosexual lifestyle that's not
very hetero a heterosexual Man Loves a
Woman and stands by her and wants to get
deeper and deeper into the relationship
just banging random people that's what
homosexuals do you're a queer if you
Bank lots of chicks
Andrew Tate the reason that he was
really canceled is young people uh uh
young boys started quoting him and that
scared the [ __ ] out of these fat leftist
Marxist teachers because they'd hear the
quote but the reason that those young
boys were quoting Andrew Tate is because
you [ __ ] not you but the teachers
okay
telling them that they suck that that
boys are evil that you know they
abandoned the term boys will be boys and
boys are punished more in school and
they're dumber and they're they have to
go if they're too rambunctious they have
to go take Adderall or or um uh what's
the other one there uh because they have
ADHD yeah Ritalin
so they're being medicated out of their
masculinity so they felt so bad about
themselves that when Andrew came along
and said no you're actually good they
were happy to hear that so the boys that
were promoting the 10 12 year old boys
that were promoting Andrew Tate were
actually reacting to all the anti-male
propaganda they were getting in class
oh I tried to agree with you I think
that's perfectly said it's so funny
because
um people um they talk about how
dangerous Andrew is for the children yet
like you mentioned they're they're like
castrating children you know taking off
girls breasts giving them all these
hormones and awful things like that
um when you have like it's they're
medicating Boyhood out of them if you're
in a public school now and you're being
doing normal stuff sitting on your hands
playing with a pen you know young boys
as testosterone begins they're always
grabbing [ __ ] and looking at stuff and
doodling and looking around there I mean
they're sort of Built For War yeah and
generations ago these guys were using
that testosterone to stab their enemies
with a spear and take over another
parcel of land so they're ready for war
biologically and the teacher goes oh
he's got a problem he's rambunctious and
then they say to the mom we're gonna
have to dock him because he can't sit
still in class and he's going to get a d
oh is there any way around this well if
he gets diagnosed with ADHD then we
can't dock him because it's a medical
condition oh okay how do I do that where
you go to this psychiatrist and the
psychiatrist is in bed with the school
he gets the Kickbacks if they go to the
doctor he says yes he has ADHD oh good
now my son can have B's and C's instead
of D's yeah but we got to medicate him
so now he's on speed Adderall if you
look at the bottle it says amphetamine
sulfate it's meth
so your kid has to become a speed addict
or I'm going to flunk him out of school
that's how they treat masculinity in
boys now they medicated out of them I
mean talk about depraved we're like back
to the Aztecs now we're sacrificing
children to the woke gods
from like a selfish standpoint just
because we were talking about dating
earlier like it actually upsets me like
as a woman because like you know there
are so many women that want these
masculine men and like you said they're
just being ruined from childhood yeah
the masculinity medicated out of them
and it upsets me from a selfish
standpoint but also
um but also yeah I just I think it's
awful
that biological seed is still there the
testosterone still exists that's why the
proud boys exploded we started as a
silly podcast club uh in New York City
with 20 guys made up random rules that I
got from high school in high school if
you farted or burped and didn't say
safety then someone would call slug the
game's called Safety Slug and you get to
be the show the guys like to name five
breakfast cereals in some parts of these
things the guys to touch a doorknob uh
to stop the beating so we pulled that in
silly rules like that and just like
there's proud boys Tokyo there's proud
Boys in Africa Intel Tel Aviv there's a
chapter it's all over the world because
I didn't run around promoting it I
didn't go on a world tour handing out
pamphlets it happened organically
because the seed was there and men go
yeah I love hanging out with the guys
once a month and being with like-minded
people and having these rituals that are
secretive when the secret handshake and
all that stuff it's fun it's funny
toast agree with you um and I hope one
day and I hope very soon we can we can
sort of Go Back to Basics you know women
can be women and men could be men
um since you've been deep platformed on
so many platforms how can people follow
you follow your work um you know and
keep up with everything that you're
saying
so I'm on getter you know g-e-t-tr I'm
on gab I'm on telegram but every day I
do a show here at sensor.tv in the South
Bronx and we discuss the news in a kooky
comical way and we make fun of everyone
especially the left
perfect well Gavin I want to thank you
so much for your time um thank you for
being uncensored literally
um I really appreciate this it's been
such a pleasure speaking with you yes oh
yeah sorry we have a live show coming up
in Chicago and in New York go to
tinyurl.com censored live and you can
get tickets there we've got a meet and
greet option too where we hang out after
the show
perfect guys make sure you follow Gavin
on guesser and you check out all of that
information we need to make men men
again and women women women again so I
like it all please don't forget to hit
the Subscribe button and the like button
and Gavin thank you so much for coming
on thanks for having me it's a pleasure
see you all next week bye the Leia hail
plan show